No. Chris just told us how he ate a bag last week.
Almost like walking through the forest. I went, Oh,
I'll get my knife and fork out and eat it in,
in our Maury North Japan bears. Cause there's too many. Actually.
There's too many guys I've been there before. How was it?
What does it taste like? Not good. A part of me feels sad, but then why,
why would I feel sad about a bad, not other animals. I don't,
I don't know about you, but you did you have it as like a proper dish? I cooked,
yeah. I cooked on a grill. Ah, cause I had it in. I can sounds,
sounds terrible. Terrible. How is it?
Is it just very gaming? It's very, it's very fatty.
It's it's um, it's like beef.
It's so disgusting. Beef. That's very hard.
It's like chewing on level essentially. Like when did you get this from?
You can give them the supermarket. Yeah.
I mean you underestimate like how many different types of choice it was.
He was also like I was in,
how could I say they were just selling whale camp and that's very controversial.
You can, you can get like dolphin sat there. I mean,
cause it's one half it's like, you don't want to be like, Hey Tran,
stop doing that because it's, you know, it's your culture.
But on the other half, please stop killing whales. The subject of bears.
There's a lot of bloody bears that run wild and go into towns,
especially at the moment because a lot of the rural population is going down and
towns are actually becoming quite empty, especially in places like hockey.
And there's a light there's going to be there. I'm going to get in.
I'm going to get a piece of the, I think it's sort of,
it's not this cover sheet then they're like,
well the can just leave it for dead or we could eat. And then they sell it.
Whereas like I think this year there was like the most amount of bear attacks in
like the last like 10, 15 years or something.
But in Hokkaido they have Brown bears on the mainland.
We've just only got black bears, which are kind of small.
Not they only eat like for
[inaudible] vegetable
[inaudible] but the Brown bears in Hokkaido. When I was driving,
I showed a bunch of signs. You didn't see anybody? I didn't see any,
but there was signs everywhere.
They're like 20 people camping on Hokkaido to bed.
Just turn up and ate everyone, everyone, everyone, they all die.
The feast lucky bag. How do you defend yourself from a bear attack in Japan?
Cause Lisa's like America. You people can carry guns, bear spray.
[inaudible] does it work? Does anyone like pepper spray for bears?
I think by the time the bag gets so close, you're already kind of.
It's gotta be like, Oh, I've got my spray. If it hits you, you're dead.
Chris brought, I read it. I read an article that a,
there was a bear turned up on, uh, uh, Oh, an orchard in Elmore.
It was lots of apples. And they were like, just doing the orchard. You know,
you want your D like a farmer and the bear just turned up. I was like, ah,
and this old man just went and just punched it in the face of the bed was like,
just ran away.
So you defended yourself against the bed. Just punch it.
Where's Chris broad punching a bad video.
That's I want to raise the level this year. I did say
I like that would be a low change from a bear. I liked that. Uh,
you know that they're nice.
It's hard because I think a lot of audiences would see that and would be a bit
part off. And it's kind of hard to,
I guess there are a lot of things like that where it's like,
you do want to kind of be like, well, this is what they do.
And this is how they've always done it. I guess it's almost like,
who are you to say? They can't do it, but at times again,
it's like the whale stuff, right? It's like, yeah, it's pretty iffy.
It's difficult subjects I had whale wants to know to never have oil. Again.
It doesn't even, it doesn't even taste good. No cruel. Isn't it. I felt so.
I was like, well, you know, I was served at an eight. What was that as well?
It's like, Oh, that's very sad. Now. I hated knowing what it was.
And I was just like,
I don't even like the post because I can't even get behind it. Anyway,
most countries have agreed to stop it. And Japan just like
[inaudible], it's not that popular in Japan. The reason it
still does well is the, uh,
the politicians in power, their areas rush for whale and they kind of have
to get voted. It's all political. It's not because people actually normally
have the taste away. A lot of the older generation do like still
a lot of them like grow up, eating it after world war two, there
was a lot of whales. So the same thing with dolphins, I would assess dolphins.
[inaudible]
in that little neighborhood. Tight happy Creek. Yeah.
Japan. It's a lot of weird food. Yeah. I feel like they just, you know,
they just go through like the little mermaid and just like, I'll have that.
These people, I don't, I don't think I've met anyone.
Who's eaten dolphin before. I've never eaten dolphin,
but I'm pretty sure they're being sold,
which is why when that documentary came out, um, what was it called? Uh,
the code, the code Japan got loads of hate. Yeah.
Japanese people are like, Oh, we don't even know we don't dolphin. What?
And they're not surprised as well when it
[inaudible] fishing community. I've seen it being sold before, but I've never,
I've never known anyone. Who's actually eaten and enjoyed it to lump a
country together. Really. Unfortunately. I mean,
Japan is quite huge and all the,
all the different prefectures do feel really different. Each other like special.
Oh, you go to every different prefecture and you're like,
what's the specialty here? And I like living in Japan.
I kind of like understand the gift culture a bit more here because like every
way you travel to there's something unique for its wine. Yeah, exactly.
There's something unique about every place you go to.
And I didn't know if they've just like five headed,
like the tourists kind of gift. Pretty sure they have. Yeah.
It feels good to like,
come back from a place and actually have a souvenir that's unique in that
we've all been to like this kind of country or this place where you, like,
you feel like you have to get a souvenir just to get a,
and you get like the most tacky, little key chain or something like that.
Would you like a fridge magnet? Exactly. I do feel like the UK. I don't know.
Did you have a do souvenirs? I didn't have a pool of souvenirs back,
but I feel obliged to hear
[inaudible] whales Wells, a little rock camp. So same thing in Brighton,
Brighton, Brighton, near beaches.
They have chocolates that look like you want to with your teeth.
It's like just this sugar. Like it has the, like,
I guess the structure of rock, but it's just sugar and you just, just,
it just sounds like a lump of sugar, but British people don't have teeth.